[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كانت اول وزيره مسلمه وثالثه شخص
مسلم يتولى منصبا وزاريا في تاريخ
الحكومات البريطانيه وحين حملت عضويه مجلس
الوردات في عام 2007 باتت اصغر اعضائه سنا
هي البارونه السعيده وارسي التي ولدت في
مارس من عام 1971 حين نشات في اسره فقيره
مسلمه هاجرت من باكستان الى انجلترا املا
في تحسين احوالها المعيشه اصبحت وارسم
حاميه بعد ان درست القانون وقتها كان
النقاش داخل الدوائر المسلمين في بريطانيا
يدور حول مدى حقيقه الفتاه المسلمه في
الدراسه الجامعيه وما اذا كان المجتمع
المسلم يرحب لبناته بتعليم الماليه تقول
وارسي ان التحدي الذي واجهته تمثل في نظره
العنصريه الى غير البيض فكان العراق ولون
البشره هو الاساس في التقييم للهويه
الدينيه كما يحدث اليوم انضمت وارسي الى
حزب المحافظين وتدرجت في المناصب سواء
داخل الحزب ام في الحكومه
ممثله له وفي عام 2010 تراست الحزب فصبت
اهتمامها على ان تكون ابواب الحزب مفاتحه
على جميع المسلمين وان تترسخ لدى الحزب
قناعه بضروره ان يحكم لمصلحه كل الشعب
وفئاته شغلت مارسي مواقع وزاريه عند
ابرزها وزير دوله في وزاره الخارجيه
البريطانيه لكنها استقالت في عام 2014
احتجاجا على الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
وهي خطوه حظيت باشاده واسعه في العالمين
العربي والاسلامي حيث طالبت الحكومه
البريطانيه باقران الاقوال بالافعال
وتنفيذ السياساتها المعلنه تجاه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ترى هو ارسلنا حزب المحافظين
لم يعد ذلك الحزب الذي انضمت اليه قبل
عقود فبلاضافه الى الماخذ المعتاده عليه
في ملفاته حقوق المراه والعنصريه
الاجتماعيه واصبحت سياسات الانفاق لدى
الحزب تبتسم بكثير من البلد بصوره قد تؤثر
على مستقبل بريطانيا مشاهدينا الكرام
المحاميه والسياسيه البريطانيه من اصول
الباكستانيه البارونه سعيده وارسي ضيفه
حلقه الليله من المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
عود للطفوله ما هو اصعب شيء بنسبه لشخص
يكون بريطاني مسلم من اصول باكستانيه
فكرت كثيرا في اصولي بل لم افكر في هويتي
الدينيه وكيف سيؤثر ذلك على فرص في الحياه
الحقيقه انني كبرت في بيت مكون من غرف نوم
واحده بالاضافه الى غرفه معيشه في الطابق
الاسفل لابن كان يعمل في المطحنه وكان
مهاجرا ولم يكن لدينا الكثير وهذا رسخ
عندي حقيقه ان الحياه الشاقه على الرغم من
ان البيت كان سعيدا وكنا نتغذى بشكل جيد
وتعلمنا ان نحمد الله اننا نتمتع بهذه
الاساسيات حين انظر حولي وارى الفرس
والادوات المتاحه لجيل اليوم استذكر انها
لم تكن موجوده اصلا في زمن وانا صغيره
[موسيقى]
لتلك الفرصه التي تمنح لمهاجر يصبح غنيا
في ما بعد
لا اشك ان صناعه حياه الناجحه وصعود في
سلم المجتمع امر بات اصعب واشق ولاسيما
النجيل والدي شعره حقيقه بانه في معرض
تغيير نمط حياتهم وهو ما فعله بحق فوالدي
مثلا ينتمي لاسره فقيره جدا وحين وصل الى
بريطانيا كان في جيبه جنيهان الى غيره
لكنه كان يحمل اصرارا على العمل بجد وكان
ذلك في عام
1962 حيث سبقه جدي عام 58 وكانوا مصرين
اسرارا قاطعا على تغيير حياتهم اذ لم يكن
لديهم خيار اخر كما كان لديهم اسر كبيره
تركوها في باكستان تعتمد على نجاحهم في
تحقيق دخل جيد ولكن ما ارادوه لنا كان
مختلفا عن ما توفر لهم هو الحصول على
التعليم والذي امنوا بضروره كمفتاح لتغيير
حياه الاسره والخروج من حاله الفقر
والنجاح ومن الملاحظ ان الاباء ذوي الاصول
الاسيويه كانت رؤيته واضحه حول المهن
والتخصصات التي اردون ان نمتهينها فانا
مثلا واحده من خمس بنات وترتيب الثانيه
ومساله الترعرع في اسره مكونه من بنات
كانت ذات خصوصيه لذلك كبرنا جميعا ونحن
نحمل قناعه باننا مختلفون بل في بعض مناح
المجتمع كان والداي يعدان فاشلان لانهما
لم ينجبه ولدا ذكرا بل اكاد اجزم اننا كنا
خمسه لانهما بقيان يحاولان انجاب ولد ذكر
ولكن في نهايه المطاف من خلال التعليم
الذي اتيح لنا استطعنا تغير حياتنا واذكر
ان امي كانت تقول لنا بوضوح ينبغي ان
تتفوقنا على الاولاد وشعرت بانها ارادت ان
تكون ناجحات لان المجتمع كان يشير اليها
بانها لم تنجح بسبب عدم انجابها ولدا ذكرا
حينما تعرفنا واشرت لك انني من من اسره
بدويه قلت ان هناك شيء مشترك ما هي طبيعه
اسره وارسي قبل مجيء اهل البريطانيه
ايضا فجور عائله من اسيا الوسطى وبلاد
القوقاز ثم رحلوا الى كشمير ثم انتقلوا
الى البنجاب ثم بعدها الى المملكه المتحده
وانا عندي ابنتان تحولت للاقامه في قطر
واحداهما تزوجت من رجل امريكي
المسلم البريطاني تحديدا وهو يكبر خاصه في
المراحل الدراسيه سواء الابتدائيه
والثانويه او حتى الجامعيه هل تم اشكال او
تحدي حقيقي يواجه الطالب المسلم في تلك
الفتره التي عشت فيها
تحديث التي واجهتها انا تختلف بشكل كبير
عن التحديات التي يواجهها اليوم الشباب
المسلم فالتحديات التي واجهتها قبل حوالي
30 او 40 سنه في المدرسه الثانويه كانت
تمثل في حوار ساخن داخل المجتمع المسلم
حول احقيه المراه المسلمه في الدراسه في
الكليه او الجامعه وعما اذا كنا نرحب
بتعليم فاضعه علماني لذا فالكثير من
النساء المسلمات لم يتلقين تعليمهن العالي
ولم يحصلن على وظائف ومهن بعد ذلك بسبب
مواقف اسرهم بالنسبه لموقف والدتي فاعتقد
ان واقعنا كخمس بنات في ظل ثقافه سائده في
مجتمعاتنا تشير الى انه لو حصل امر ما في
حياه البنت فانها ستكون بحاجه لرجل هو
ابوها او اخوها لكي يساعدها وكانت امي
تعلم انه ليس لدينا ذلك الاخ ولذلك حرصت
على ان مستقلات ماديا والوسيله الوحيده كي
نحقق ذلك هي من خلال تلقينا تعليما جيدا
لذلك فالتحديات التي واجهتها على صعيد
التعليم كانت من نوع مختلف بالطبع كان
هناك ايضا تحدي سقف التوقعات وطموح
المنخفض فعلى رغم انني اردت دراسه القانون
وان اصبح محاميه كانت تصور السائد ان مثل
هذه المهنه لا تليق بامراه مسلمه بينما
اليوم اذا ما نظرنا الى المسلمين
البريطانيين الشباب فالتحديات التي
تواجههم تتعلق بهويتهم فحين كنت اجبر لم
تكن قضيه كوني مسلمه اشكاليه فالتحديات
كانت تتمحور حول قضيه العرق كنا نعرف من
خلال لون بشرتنا لا من خلاله هويتنا دينيه
وبذلك في النشاطات التي تميت اليها
واسانتها بعد ذلك كانت تتعلق بالحقوق
والعداله للحريه الدينيه بين الشباب
المسلم اليوم لا يعلم شيئا سوى العالم
بهيئته التي تشكلت بعد حقبه الحرب على الا
وبذلك فوجوده بشكل كامل محدد ضمن الاطار
الامني وذلك اكثر صعوبه كنا نكافح لنيل
المساواه جنبا الى جن مع المسيحيين
والهندوس واليهود والسيخ والسود فكان
تحالف اكثر شمولا بينما الشباب المسلم
البريطاني يكافح اليوم وحيدا
المحافظين بينما جرت الاعداء يعني انه
معظم المهاجرين يذهبون للحزب الاخر حزب
العمال الحزب الحزب المحافظين حزب
التقليدي لديه مواقف همم ليست ايجابيه في
معظمها تجاه المهاجرين
الامر الاول هو ان مجرد الانضمام لعالم
السياسه كان خطوه هائله بحد ذاتها وحين
اصبحت جزءا من واجهه العمل السياسي لم يكن
هناك مسلمات في مواقع سياسيه بل كانت هناك
حوارات ساخنه حول شرعيه وجود نساء في
مواقع قياديه داخل المجتمع المسلمين
وخارجه بل حين ترشحت في انتخابات لاول مره
عام 2004 كان هناك جدال في المجتمع
البريطاني الابيض حول عدم امكانيه التصويت
لامراه فضلا عن كونها امراه هي ذات بشره
سمراء كما كان هناك جدال داخل المساجد حول
شرعيه وجود النساء المسلمات في مواقع
قياديه لذا فقد كانت هذه الحوارات لافته
ومثيره ان ذلك بشان المراه في مجال
السياسه بالنسبه لي ولقرار دخول حزب
المحافظين فانا انحذر من عائله ذات توجه
سياسي متنوعه فوالدي صوت لصالح العمال
بينما والدته طالما صوته
محافظين ولكن الشيء المشتركه هو الاعتقاد
بانك لو عملت بجد واجتهاد فانك ستحسن من
وضعك المعيشي وعمليه الارتقاء الاجتماعي
كانت عاملا اساسيا في تلك القناعه كما ان
عائله انتهى بها المطاف في عالم التجاره
والاعمال وهي عائله تؤمن بقيم اسريه
محافظه كما انني شخصيا محافظتا اؤمن
بحكومه صغيره وبضرائب منخفضه
او بمساله العنصريه الاجتماعيه فحسب
المحافظين يعتبر متاخرا ولكن الامر
بالنسبه لي لم يتعلق بقضيه فرديه
عامه واعتقد ان قناعات كانت اكثر تجانسا
مع حزب المحافظين اما اذا سالتني هل هي
متجانسه مع حزب المحافظين كما هو اليوم
فلست متاكده ان حزب المحافظين اليوم هو
محافظه حقا
لو اتخذت القرار اليوم تذهبين اتجاه معاكس
لحزب العمال
حزب المحافظين يسرحون بان حزب المحافظين
اليوم ليس هو الحزب الذي انضمنا اليه في
اول الامر ولكن هذا يضعنا امام سؤال هل
نبقى نناضل لاجل اعاده الحزب لخطه الصحيح
كما كان حين تمينا اليه اي ان نعيده حزبا
وسطا وفتحا ويرحب بالجميع او نتركه ليصبح
اسوا مما هو عليه الان وارى ان الكثير من
اتخذ القرار حيل وضع الحزب والذي بات في
موضع اجتماعيا في غايه الغرابه حول قضايا
مختلفه ومن الناحيه الاقتصاديه نراه ينفق
اموالا طائله كما لو ان يوم غد لا ياتي
نجد هذا الحزب في مكان عجيب الامر الاخر
الذي يجعلني محاضره هو ايمان العميق
بالعمليه الديمقراطيه وسلطه القانون
والنظام المبني على القواعد وحسب يقوم على
رعايه القانون والعداله وفي هذا الصدد
ايضا اعتقد انه هناك الكثير من علامات
الاستفهام حول مدى فهم الحزب الحاليه لهذه
المقومات فتبقى مهمتنا الاساسيه هي
تذكيرهم دوما بهذا الامر وكيف ينبغي ان
يكون المحافظ حقا
حينما
في عام 2010 لم تستطيعي فعل كثير في تغيير
مسار هذا الحزب افكاره همم تفاعل مع
الواقع الجديد
بين 2005 و25 ولو تمعنت في الخطابات التي
القاها زعيم الحزب ان ذات كاميرا حول ما
يعنيها ان تكون مسلما خصوصا بالمقارنه مع
التعريفات السابقه لمصطلحات كالاسماويه
والتطرف فلا شك انها لم تكون كامله
ولكنني اشعر باننا كنا قد بدانا في مسيره
التعلم بحق على هذه القضيه كما غيرنا
كثيرا من وجه الحزب ومن شكلها وكانت
الحوارات الداخليه
للمسلمين وقضايا اخرى ذات صله بالمجتمع
المسلم ولكن هذه المسائل الى تحتاج الى
وقت لكي تنضج وما يمكنني قوله هو ان
المسيره التي بدات وهي تبتسم بالكثير من
الايجابيه قد تعطلت او توقفت نوعا ما تحت
القياده الحاليه للحزب
يشعر البعض انه كان هناك احتفال او ان
هناك طريقا يعني يقال ممهدا مفروشا
بالورود لسعيده وارسل لتولي عضويه مجلس
الاوردات لدخول ايضا الحكومه البريطانيه
بخلاف ما حدث في ال- في الاخير يعني حدث
نوع من الصدام
وساعه العلاقه في البدايه لماذا هل كان
هناك احتفال بك هل كان يراد لمسلم ان يكون
شخصيه بارزه في حزب المحافظين
لا ادري اذا كان الامر رايي منتشرا في
المجتمع ولكن كان هناك من داخل الحزب ما
يظن ان علي ان اكون ممتنه لانني حملت
حقائب ذات اهميه وان علي ان لا اثير
اشكالات كما كنت افعل بينما انا مقتنعه
انه لا قائل من تحمل مسؤوليه مناصب وسلطات
اذا لم اكن لاستثمر السلطات الممنوحه
لاحداث تغييرات حقيقيه شخصيا لست سياسيه
وعالم سياسه ليس عالم لطيفا بل هو عالم
يبعث على الشعور بالوحده عالم شاق وعمل
يدفع الكثير من الناس الى ان تكرهك ولا
اعتقد ان السياسه يحبذ ان يختارها الناس
كم مهنه لهم لذلك في حال وجدت نفسك في
عالم السياسه كما وجدت نفسي وتمتلك شيئا
من السلطه والصلاحيه وقدرا من القدره على
اتخاذ القرار فاما ان تقضي وقتك وانت
وذلك المنصب وتعمل على اي حبك من حولك او
يمكنك ان تمارس تلك السلطات ما قد يجلب لك
كراهيه البعض
حينما دخلت مجلس الوردات ثم بعد ذلك توليت
رئاسه حزب المحافظين من الاولويات التي
تتبناها سعيده وارسي همم كاسياسيها
من الهموم الاول هو ان يكون حزب المحافظين
حزب منفتحا لجميع المسلمين البريطانيين
وقد بدانا العنايه بهذا الامر فكان عندنا
عدد اكبر من المرشحين ومن ممتازه في
الانتخابات البلديه كما عندنا عدد اكبر من
ما يتفاعلوا معنا وينضم الى صفوف الحزب
ويدعم الحزب ماديا ومعنويا
الحزب الحاكم ان عليه ان يحكم لمصلحه كل
الشعب وكافه فئاته ومن ضمنهم المجتمعات
المسلم
من الازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه وكنا نعاني
من مديونيه العاليه وكان علينا اعاده
الاقتصاد لخط سيره الطبيعي لذلك كان كل
شيء يتمحور حول الاقتصاد بغض النظر عن
المجتمع الذي ينتمي اليه المواطن ففي حال
استق الاقتصاد الوطني ستسير الامور بشكل
اكثر انسيابيه ونجاحا ولكن حين تتاثر
الظروف المعيشيه للناس ستنجم عن ذلك
مشاحنات وتوترات بين المجتمعات المختلفه
اذا فقد كان في مصلحه سائر فئات المجتمع
البريطاني ان نعيد ترتيب الملف الاقتصادي
اعتقد ان اهتمام الاخر كان محاوله لتهن
ابعاد واثار الحرب على الارهاب ومعنى
التطرف بطريقه اكثر دقه وتفصيلا فقد كان
من بين اكبر المشكلات خلال فتره بوش وبلار
انهم انشاوا ارضيه مقسمه بالابيض والاسود
فاما ان تكون معنا او ان تكون ضدنا وان
الامر مرده الى الفكر ثم ادخال مصطلح
الاسلام الامويه ضمن السياق العام وهو
مصطلح يحمل حوالي 22 تعريفا لها فما الذي
يعنيه ذلك المصطلح وكيف اثر ذلك كله على
اسلوب تعاطينا مع باقي العالم وتعاطينا
وتفاعلنا مع مجتمعاتنا المحليه وامر اخر
يتعلق بشع العلمانيه لقد حرصت ان اجعل من
الدين عامل فهم لهذه الحوارات وان يكون
طرفا فاعلا في تلك التفاعلات الفكريه
والسياسيه واذكره هنا كيف ان المستشار
الاعلاميه لتوني بلير الاستركامبل قال
يوما نحن لا نلعب دور الاله وفي احدى
خطابات الاولى حين كنت في الحكومه قلت هذه
الحكومه تلعب دور الاله والذي عنيته بذلك
هو ان المتدينين يمكنهم ان يلعب دورا
ايجابيا وان الذين يمكن ان يكون ذا اثر
ايجابي بل يجب ان يكون جزءا من حل
المعضلات الكبرى والملفته هو انني حين
تركت الحكومه كانت احدى شهادات المتميزه
التي قدمت بحقي كتبتها مجله مسيحيه اذ
ذكرت انه بالتركي سعيده وارسي موقعها في
الحكومه خسرت الكنيسه حديثها المفضله في
الحكومه اذا فقناعتي ان الدين وليس
الاسلام حصرا ينبغي ان يكون جزءا لا يتجزا
من الحوار العام لذلك فمن افضل الموا عله
خدمت فيها الحكومه كانت حين تقلدت منصب
وزيره دوله لشؤون الدين والمجتمع
كيف ينظر ال ال البريطانيين بين قوسين
الاصليين لتنام ظاهره وجود مهاجرين في
مواقع قياديه مثل ابو عرسي مثل العمده
لندن مثل كثير من السياسيين سواء في حزب
المحافظين او في الاحزاب الاخرى كيف
ينظرون اليوم لوجودكم في مواقع متقدمه
بل انا مقتنعه انه رغم الاشكالات الكثيره
التي نعاني منها الان بريطانيا لا تزال من
اكثر الدول والمجتمعات تسامحا وقد اتيحت
لي الفرصه ان اسافر حول العالم وانا
مقتنعه بحق انه ليست هناك بقعه على الارض
مثل بريطانيا من حيث التنوع والتعدديه
والفهم المشترك وبالنسبه له فما يهمني بحق
ويدفعني لتصريح حول قضايا مثل الاسلام
فوبيا والعنصريه والمساواه هو انني ارى ان
نتراجع شيئا فشيئا وما نراه من حروب
ثقافيه داخل الحكومه يعكس ما حدث في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو امر طارق و
غريب على الفطره البريطانيه فمبدا ان تعيش
وتترك غيرك يعيش ومبدا التسامح ومبدا
التعدديه دوما كانت مبادئ حاكمه في
المجتمع نعم بالتاكيد ستكون هناك حالات من
العنصريه ولكن في سياق حومه الكليه
للمجتمع البريطاني لا اظن ذلك جزءا اصيلا
من تركيبه المجتمع حسب
تاريخ طويل بالهجره المسلمين الى المملكه
المتحده بدا في القرن السادس عشر وتحديد
الربان حكم الملكه اليزابيث الاولى ظلت
وتيره هجره المسلمين الى البلاد التي كانت
لا تغيب عنها الشمس بطيئه جدا حتى اربع
ايام القرن الماضي حين شرعت اعداد كبيره
من مسلم الهند وباكستان وبنجلاديش
بالتوافد على مهدي الامبراطوريه التي
حكمتهم ردحا من الزمن وبحسب الارقام شبه
الرسميه يعيش في بريطانيا نحو اربعه
ملايين مسلم يمثلون اكثر من خمسه بالمئه
من السكان بينما يناهز عدد العرب منهم نحو
350,000 وفي حين تشير الاحصاءات الى ان
واحده من بين كل سبعه من سكان بريطانيا
اريد في الخارج تتحدث بعض التقارير عن
صعوبات تواجه عمليه اندماج المهاجرين
المسلمين بشكل خاص لاعتبارات دينيه وثق
واجتماعيه وسياسيه فمنذ سنوات وتحديد
عقيبه وقوعها هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
زادت معدلات الكراهيه والعنصريه ضد
المسلمين على الرغم من ان بريطانيا لا
تزالوا البقعه الاوروبيه الاقل سلبيا تجاه
هؤلاء وفق ما تشير اليه دراسات ترى ان
المملكه المتحده نجحت في الفصل بين
المظاهر الدينيه والحياه العمليه مع عزيزه
من سهوله انخراط المسلمين بالمجتمع بخلاف
دول اخرى مثل فرنسا ولعل وجود نحو 1300
مسجد فضلا عن تولي عشرات المسلمين مناصب
سياسيه الرفيعه يؤكد ان مسلم بريطانيا قد
تجاوزوا تحديات المهمه ولكن يبدو ان
الاصعب لم ياتي بعد
برايك السيده وصلتي لماذا يواجه المسلمون
على على وجه التحديد
تحديات اكبر من غيرهم في اوروبا في
البلدان التي يعيشون فيها في كل مكان
دائما هناك قضيه تواجه المسلم
والاسلام كثير والاسلام كثافه بشكل
استثنائي عن عن ديانات اخرى عن ثقافات
اخرى هل تم تشييع خاص بهذا الامر من وجهه
نظرك
لدى المسلمين في بريطانيا
قد تمت صياغتها ضمن سياق احداث 11 من
سبتمبر وما تبعها وبغض النظر عن ما يكونون
وماذا حققوا وماذا انجزوا اجرينا دراسه
مؤخرا بحثنا فيها عن طبيعه العنصريه التي
يواجهها المسلمون وواجبنا الا صله للامر
بممارستهم او شعائرهم كما لا علاقه له
بلباسهم او ازيائهم او بعدد المرات التي
يقيمون فيها الصلاه وجدنا بالامكان ان
يتعرض الانسان للاستهداف لمجرد جسمه وذلك
لانه مع مرور الوقت حدثت بعض المسائل
وتكرست بعض النمطيات حول المجتمعات
المسلمه وهكذا تتطور العنصريه وهذه
النمطيات توحيد ببساطه بانه مجتمع لا
ينتمي الى اوروبا ولكن هذا الامر ليس
جديدا علينا كمجتمعا بريطاني فقد مر علينا
زمن كنا نشعر فيه بان المجتمع الكاثوليكي
لا ينتمي للمملكه المتحده وان ولاء
الكاثوليكيين هو للبابا وبذلك فلا يمكن
الوثوق بهن كما مر علينا زمن شعرنا بالامر
نفسه حيل المجتمع اليهودي شعارنا ان
ولائهم ليس مع البلد وبانهم يخلد في مكان
اخر وبذلك فهم من خلال تصرفاتهم يشكلون
طابورا خامسا لذلك من الاهميه بمكان ان
ننظر لهذه القضيه ضمن رؤيه تاريخيه حيث
يبدو ان كل فتره الزمنيه بحاجه
يناسب ذلك الوقت ونحن الان في الحقبه التي
احداث الاحادي عشر من سبتمبر والحرب على
الارهاب
المسلمون في بريطانيا وفي اوروبا يعرفون
من خلال تلك الرؤيه لا شك ان الامر بالغ
الصعوبه ام تقضي وقتك وانت تكافح تلك
النمطيات ولكن الطريقه الافضل هي من خلال
العقل والمنطق والحقائق وما حاولت فعله في
كتاب هو التركيز على هذه المعايير فمثلا
لو نظرنا الى ضحايا العمليات الارهابيه
التي ارتكبها مسلمون في الغرب مقابل
الاعمال الارهابيه التي قام بها غيرهم من
امثال اليمنيين المتطرفين فالاقام متفاوته
بشكل كبير جدا اعداد المسلمين المتورطين
في هذه الاعمال اقل بكثير جدا من الاخرين
ولكن الامر مرتكز على التنميه وهو تحدي
يواجهه المسلمون البريطانيون الاوروبيون
لقد بات للاسف امرا تماسس ضمن رؤيه وخطاب
وممارسات الدوله وطريقه حديث السياسيين عن
المسلمين
يعني اليمين المتطرف بشكل عام في اوروبا
وفي العالم يبدو ان المسلمين تواجههم يعني
سنوات صعبه في سواء في بريطانيا او في
اوروبا
او ما حصل في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لذلك اقول اننا ان كنا قلقين بشان التطرف
فعلينا ان نكون قلقينا ازاء التطرف اليمني
وذلك لان هناك كثيرين من فئه المجتمع
الكثيره من من هم عرضه للانجذاب لمثل هذا
الخط هم اكثر بكثير مما يمكن ان ينجذب لخط
التطرف الاسلامي اذا نعود مره اخرى لقضيه
تغير المناخ السياسي في الغرب وارتفاع
منسوب الشعبيه وزياده حده العنصريه ولكن
اعود للسبب الرئيسي لما يحصل ولا عدنا الى
ما قبل ال 11 من سبتمبر فانا لم اكن اعرف
نفسي من خلال ديانتي ولم يكن الدين بحكم
الهويه حينما كنت اكبر فالناس كانت تعرف
ان ذات بانهم سود واسيويون بريطانيون اما
الان فالامر مختلف تماما والخطوره ليست
انك تكافح النوع من انواع العنصريه
المبنيه على لون بشرتك ولكنه مبني على
ايديولوجيه تشابه تلك التي نراها في الهند
وفي بورما وفي اجزاء من الغرب ايضا وكذلك
في الصين ما يجعل هذه الصيغه الجديده من
هذه العنصريه التي يواجهها المسلمون اكثر
تعقيدا من صديقتها
اليوم في ظل الحكومه
المتطرفه ومتعصبه تواجه المسلمين بعنف
استثنائي ا- عصير
الديربينج
انجي الامر مزعج للغايه فطالما كانت الهند
قائمه على اسس دوله علمانيه ترعى
المجتمعات المختلفه والتي تشكل الشعب
الهندي بل للسنوات طويله جادل البعض ان
الانقسام بين الهند وباكستان لم يكن ينبغي
ان يحصل وكان المفروض ان تبقى الهند بلدا
وشعبا واحدا يتمتع الجميع فيه بالمساواه
بينما يجادل انصار التقسيم ان مشروعا
فيصلي باكستان كان لازما نظرا لان
المسلمين في جنوب الهند لم يشعروا انهم
يتمتعون بالحمايه تحت ظل دوله هنديه
علمانيه والحقيقه ان ما فعلته حكومه وحزب
به الحاكم هو اثبات صحه وصواب التقسيم بل
وضرورته نظرا لطريقه القنائه التي تتعامل
فيها الحكومه مع مسلمها الحقيقه هذه
القضيه تمسني بشكل مباشر فقط كبرت في
مقاطعه يوركشاير بمعيه شباب ترعرعنا
اذكرنا معهم وعرفنا اهاليهم ووجدنا لاحقا
تورطهم في ثورات بجارات حيث قتلوا هناك في
وقت كان مذي هو الوزير الاول الحاكم
لولايه كوجارات ولذلك لا يساويني ادنى شك
ان يديه ملوثه بالدماء كما ان جثث هؤلاء
الشباب لم تسلم لاهاليهم كي يتم دفنهم
بطريقه لائقه وكان الغرب على معرفه تامه
بكل ذلك وكانت المملكه المتحده تعرف كما
الولايات المتحده ولذلك وضعنا مبدع على
قائمه المحظورين فلم نستقبله ولم نتعاطى
معه ولم نكن نعتبره سوى متطرف وشخص ارتكبه
واجج كراهيه المجتمعيه
ولكنه للاسف اصبح لاحقا رئيسا وزراء الهند
ولم يبقى امامنا خيارا سوى ان نتعامل مع
هذا الرجل ولكنني اعتقد ان العالم بدا يرى
الوجه الحقيقي لمدير ولحكومته وما فعله في
اثاره وتاجيج الكراهيه والانقسام كوزيرا
لججارات كرسه وهو رئيس وزراء للهند والذي
اموله هو ان يكون العالم اجمع على قدر من
الشجاعه حتى يدينه لما فعل وما يقوم به من
تدمير للهند من الداخل من خلال هذا النمط
البشع من التطرف
بريطانيا
السياسات ويواجه شخص متطرف مثل مودي كما
في حاله اخرى لان لم يواجه به بقوه توازي
ما قام به من بشاعات تجاه المسلمين
تملك هذا القدر من التاثير على الهند
بالتاكيد فالمملكه المتحده لديها حاجه
ماسه للهند ما يدفعها لصياغه علاقتها معها
وفقا اليه برغماتيه ورغم التطنيننا خلال
زياره الاخيره لبوريس جونسون للهند بانه
سيثير هذه القضايا فان الواقع يفرض اننا
وبعد خروجنا من الاتحاد الاوروبي مهتمون
غايه الاهتمام بالملف الاقتصاديه لذلك في
اعتقادي اننا سنضع التجاره فوق القيم التي
نؤمن بها
هل هي جيده بما فيه الكفايه صالحه بما فيه
الكفايات معبره عنهم كمسلمين او كمسلمه
بما فيه الكفايه لان قرات بعض التعليقات
التي تخالفك كثيرا في مساله المسلم
كيف
حاول مسلم
هذا صحيح وقد تغيرت هذه النظره عبر
السنوات فقط
من المجتمع المسلم مصره على عدم وجود
المراه في مواقع قياديه وان المسلم لا
ينبغي له ان يكون في حزب المحافظين
بالنسبه لي فطالما كنت صريحه وواضحه دون
ان اخشى لومه لائم ولم اطلب يوما او افعى
لتمثيل مسلم بريطانيا كما لم افعل التحدث
باسمي مسلم بريطانيا بل عن قضايا اعتقد
انها تمس جانب العداله الاجتماعيه
المسلم هو اننا في طريق سير طويل واجد
الذين قالوا لي قبل 20 سنه لا ندري لما
تخوضين غمار السياسه يقولون لي الان كم
نحن سعداء انك فعلتي ودخلتي عالم
كما اجد من تساءلوا لما دخلت حزب
المحافظين يقولون لي اليوم ان من الضروري
ان ابقى في حزب المحافظين كي يظل الحزب
يتمتع بشيء من العقلنيه
ارجو ان لا ابدو مغروره حين اقول انما
يظنه المجتمع المسلم عني بل ما يظنه اي
شخص عني لا يعنيني بقدر ما اذا كانت
قراراتي والخطوات التي اتخذها والتصريحات
التي اطلقها في حياه المهنيه ترضي ضميري
وتحقق امالي لانه في نهايه المطاف ينبغي
ان اكون راضيه عن نفسي قبل ان يرضى عني اي
شخص اخر متوافقه مع قيام ومبادئه ولم اكن
اؤدي دورا كي يعجب الجماهير به ولكن يبقى
الامر الذي اشعر
بالامتنان الشديد الان وبعد هذه السنوات
الطويله في هذه المسيره انني اجد المجتمع
اكثر تقبلا حتى لو لم يكن موافقا لذا
فاجدني اليوم اجري مناقشات مع ائمه من طرف
ومع القيادات الشابه من طرف اخر ولا يسعني
في نهايه الامر الا ان ادعم هذه المسيره
واحاول ترشيدها قدر
المستطاعس منصب الوزاره كاول وزير مسلم في
حكومه بريطانيه كنت قادره على فعل شيء ام
ان الماء الامر مجرد يعني محاوله من
الحكومه الاظهار التنوع وكسب ايضا الناخب
المسلمين
امم
[موسيقى]
توازن 2 عدد اعضاء مجلس الوزراء اقل من 30
وحين دخلت مجلس الوزراء كنا في حكومه
ائتلاف فكان حزبان يشكلان الحكومه في عام
2010 ولا اعتقد ان ادخال امراه مسلمه لم
يكن خطوه ضروريه وانا من بين هؤلاء
الثلاثين كان لزاما ان يكون احدهم مسلم
واذكرك بانني كنت شخصا وحيدا من غير البيض
في تلك الحكومه
وكان بالامكان ان يكون ذلك العضو الملون
اي شخص على الاطلاق لم يكن لزاما ان يكون
مسلما لكي يجذب اصوات المسلمين ولا سيما
انه في حال كانت تلك هي الغايه فقد كان
بالامكان تعيين في مكان اخر او اعطاء
منصبا اقل ذا وزير دوله مثلا لم يكن الامر
على سبيل الديكور والشكل فقط
جيده وكانت تدور بيننا حوارات ساخنه
واختلفنا كثير منها لكنها بقيت علاقه
صريحه وواضحه وتتحلى بالثقه وكان من
الواضح انه شعر انني كنت امتلك خبره
تاهلني لتقديم اضافه بغض النظر عن ديانه
او لون بشرتي فكنت امتلك خبره في مجال
التجاره والاعمال كما كنت محاميه افهم في
القانون الجنائي ولا انكر ان وجودي اعطى
الحزب صوره ايجابيه بالتاكيد ولكن لم يكن
ذلك هو الدافع لتعيينه واعتقد ان ذلك
الكاميرا وزملائي في الحكومه علموا بشكل
سريع لانني لن اكون مجرد ديكور لا اثر
حقيقيا له
لماذا تضحي السيده بريطانيا تناظر من اجل
قضيتها كمسلم بريطانيا
وتستقيل من الحكومه في 2014 احتجاجا على
الموقف
الحكوماتها من الحرب على غزه ان كان موقفا
مقدرا جدا في العالم العربي وكان موقفا
شجاع الحقيقه لماذا شعرت انك بحاجه
للاستقاله والتوقف عن الاستمرار في العمل
الحكومي في 2014
ينبغي ادراك الدوري الرسمي الذي كنت اقوم
به انزاك فقد كنت وزيره دوله لدى وزاره
الخارجيه وكانت مسؤوليتي تتعلق بالعلاقه
مع الامم المتحده ومحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
كما كنت الوزيره المفاوضه في مجلس الوردات
ما يعني انني كنت اقف يوميا في المجلس
واجيب على تساؤلات الاعضاء حول ما يتعلق
بقضيه الاسراء
فربما لو انني كنت حينها وزيره مواصلات
مثلا او وزيره التعليم لم اكن لاتبوء
مقعدا في صفوف الاماميه فيما يتعلق بهذه
القضيه تحديدا ولم اكن شخصا مكلفه بالوقوف
في البرلمان لاقدم تصريحات الرسميه واجيب
عن الاسئله
وقع على رسائل واكتب للامم المتحده بمواقف
الحكومه فضلا عن غير ذلك مما تطلبته
المهمه
ولكن قدر لي انني كنت ذلك الشخص في ذلك
الموقع في ذلك الوقت وكنت ان المكلفه
بالتصريح امام مجلس حقوق الانسان بجناب
اننا سنمتنع عن التصويت حول قرار اداره
اسرائيل بارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
وباننا لن ندعم الطلب المقدمه لمحكمه
الجنايات الدوليه كما لن ندعم طلب
الاعتراف بدوله فلسطين ولن نساهم في اعاده
اعمار غزه بعد انتهاء الحرب كما كان علي
ان اقف مرارا واصرح بدعم الحكومه في حال
الدولتين في حين كنت اعلم تماما اننا لم
نكن نفعل شيئا اطلاقا لدعم ذلك المشروع من
خلال حمايه الاراضي الفلسطينيه واغدا
بالاعتبار انني محاميه متخصصه في مجال
حقوق الانسان لم يكن على الحزب ان يستغرب
مما قمت به فالذي فعلته عام 2014 لم يكن
له علاقه بكون مسلمه
في مجلس الوردات العام في في في مايو 2021
كان خطاب صلاح لافتت يعني انه تحدثت فيه
عن عن مساله اسرائيل والفلسطين وتقولي
لدينا سياسه حل الدولتين كما اشارتي لكننا
لا نعترف بفلسطين كدوله نحن نعترف ب 67
القدس الشرقيه جزء لا يتجزا من الدوله
الفلسطينيه لكننا لا نفعل شيء تجاه هذا
الامر تحدثت عن المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والتحقيق في الجرائم لكن البريطانيه لا
تفعل شيء تحدثت عن ما حدث في الشيخ جراح
في قضايا كثيره لماذا برايك تتخذ بريطانيا
هذا الموقف ال- ال- المنحاز وغير الاخلاق
في في القضيه الفلسطينيه
وهذا بالضبط ما يقلقني فلا شك ان كثيرا من
الدول تفعل اشياء سيئه للغايه لمواطنيها
وفي الاراضي التي تحتلها فشاني ليس ما
تفعله اسرائيل
بل قضيه هو ما تفعله حكومه ردا على ممارسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولهذا السبب شعرت ان
علي ان استقيل ولهذا السبب اسمي سياستنا
ايذاء القضيه الفلسطينيه بالمنافقه فاما
ان نقول بصراحه الامر لا يعنينا كما تفعل
بعض دول حول العالم ان نقول لا يهمنا ما
يجري للفلسطينيين ولا يعنيين الالتزام
بقرارات الامم المتحده ولا يعنينا امر
القانون الدولي بل لا تهمنا حقوق الانسان
وسيكون ذلك صعبه
لا اطيق ان نعلن التزامنا بكل ذلك ثم لا
نقوم بشيء انا لا اطلب من الحكومه
البريطانيه ان تغير من فاتها في شان
الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني بل اطالب
الحكومه بتطبيق سياستها حول هذا الصراع
الاسرائيلي قويين في بريطانيا هنا قرارات
ادانا لحماس لاطراف فلسطينيه من قرارات
تصب دائما لصالح اسرائيل هل هل الحجم هذا
اللوبي والتاثيره قوي جدا لا احد يستطيع
الوقوف في وجهه في بريطانيا
اعتقد ان هذا هو الطريق السهل لتعامل مع
هذا الموضوع فمن السهل التذرع بوجود هذا
اللوبي او ذاك وبتاثيرهم على قراراتنا حين
تدخل عالم السياسه فمن الجيد ان تطن في
العاملين في حقل السياسه بانهم اصحاب عقول
مستقله وبانهم قادرون على اتخاذ القرارات
وانهم يفهمون المصلحه الوطنيه ولكن الكثير
من قراراتنا اليوم بشان سياستنا الخارجيه
لا تحقق مصالحا من الوطنيه فلا يمكن ان
نشكو من وجود منظمات ولوبيات يقومون
بمصالحهم فهذا عملهم ولكن ما يهمني هو دور
السياسيين ان يقول لهذه المنظمات هذا
الموقف لا يخدم المصلحه الوطنيه
البريطانيا وان سياسيين يتمتعون
بالاخلاقيه والذكاء ما يجعلهم يقفون هكذا
مواقف مبدئيه لذا فاجد ان التدرع بقضيه
اللوبيات ومخرج سهل يتسم بالكثير من الكسل
ما يجب علينا فعله هو اله الحكومات
ومحاسبتها ويتم ذلك من خلال صناديق
الاقتراع بوكس
استهداف صحفيه عربيه فلسطينيه هي الراحله
شيرين ابو عاقله برصاصه مباشره من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي في عمل صحفي وكيف
شاهدتها وهي تسقط على الهواء مباشره اثناء
تاديه لامن الصحفي
شكلا لي الامر شيئا مسني بشكل خاص
فقط كانت شيرين في مثله عمري
وحياتها في خطر قالت الحقيقه لاصحاب القوه
خاضت كم من هائلا من المعارك عبر سنوات
طويله والهمت اخرين لكي يشاركوا في تلك
المعارك والحقيقه لقد صعقني ان مثل هذه
الجريمه يمكن ان ترتكبها وبهذا الشكل
الفاضح وعلى مراه ومسمع العالم بحق مثل
هذه الشخصيه البارزه بالاضافه الى ان غياب
حاله الغضب ورده الفعل اللائقه في مختلف
العواصم حول العالم اصاب بالذهول ولكن
ينبغي ان نلقينا ان هذا الامر لم ينتهي
بعد موتها يجب ان يعني لنا الكثير وخلاصه
الامر يعود لقضيه المحاسبه
وقد تحدثت بشان هذه الجريمه في البرلمان
والواقع وارجو ان لا يساء فهمي انني لم
استغرب ما حدث وذلك لان المره تلو المره
تثبت الاحداث ان اقوى الاصوات والمواقف
تصدر عن نساء وفتيات وبعض اوهن واضعف
الاصوات طالما تصدر عن زعماءنا من الرجال
الذين لا يجدون حتى الكلمات التي تنطق
بللغه
عديده سيد من بدايه حياتك اول معركه مع
البيئه المحافظه المسلمه التي تنتمي لها
هناك عده قضايا حدثت ثم في المجتمع
البريطاني كمسلمه ثم كملها
ايضا المراه ايضا لديها اشكالتها الصراحه
الا يبدو القمر منهتا بعض الشيخ يعني هل
تشعرين
بانهاك من هذه المعارك التي حطيها طوال
السنوات الماضيه
اشعر احيانا بانني خط المعارك منذ اليوم
الذي ولدت فيه كون امراه والثانيه من بين
خمس اخوات لذا فمن اليوم الاول كنت اصارع
لنيل حقي وتحقيق المساواه ولكوني نشات في
عالم الاعمال والتجاره لو نظرت الى الامر
كما تنظر الى كشف للحسابات فالاولاد يضعون
في خانه رصيد او الاصول بيننا توضع الفتاه
في خانه التابعات والاولاد يعتبرون
مساهمين بينما البنات مستهلكات والاولاد
ينظر اليهم انهم يحملون الشرف بينما البنت
تحمل العارض لذلك فمن اليوم الاول وانا
اكافح لكي احقق المساواه وبذلك تروح
المكاباته والعناد موجوده لدي منذ الولاده
وربما انظر الى الامر ان الصراعات
المستمره في شان قضايا سياسيه تجعل زوجي
سعيده اذ لا اعود املك الطاقه حتى ادخل في
معارك جدليه الحمد لله هو في البيت
ولكنني مؤمنه حقا ان هذه المعارك هي التي
تبحث عنك ولا اعتقد انني خرجت ابحث عنها
وكلنا نصل الى مفترق طرق في حياتنا حين
يمكننا ان نعود ادراجنا من حيث اتينا
ونستسلم او ان نجابها التحديات ونخوض ذلك
التحدي
جاءت اسرتك منه وهو غارق في الفساد في
الاشكاليه في التراجع في شيء يعني في درجه
عاليه من الفقر
وكانه قدر بعض البلدان المسلمه ان لا
تتجاوزين كيف تنظرين لاحوال باكستان همم
من هنا من زاويتك سياسيه بريطانيه
باكستان
على مدى عامين ونصف وانظروا الى باكستان
من زوايا عده اولا كمسقط راس جدي ووالدي و
جهه اخدمها من حيث الكثير من اعمال
الخيريه وكما كان عدت اليه من موقع كوزيره
بريطانيه ولا شك انني اعتقد ان باكستان
تتمتع بفرص هائله اذا ما نجحت في تجاوز
الانسداد السياسي واقول لها بصراحه
فالواقع السياسي والحليلي هو اسواق واقع
سياسيا وصلت اليه باكستان في تاريخها وذلك
في ظل ظروف اقتصاديه بالغه الصعوبه
باكستان ان تجد الوسيله الافضل لكي تخرج
من هذه الاسماء فبعد الاحتلال السوفيتي
لافغانستان تم تعريف باكستان من خلال
منظار في غايه الضيق الا وهو منظر الارهاب
وذلك من خلال الحرب على الارهاب والحرب
على الاتحاد السوفيتي وصعود طالبان
والحادي عشر من سبتمبر والكشف عن مكان
اسامه بن لادن فتم وضعه هذا البلد العظيم
في تلك الخانه الضيقه للغايه بينما لو
نظرت مثلا الى كل مجله سياحيه في العالم
خلال السنوات الثلاث الماضيه تجد باكستان
احدى الوجهات السياحيه العشر الرئيسيه على
مستوى العالم وبذلك فالفرص المتاحه امامها
هائله من حيث الجمال الخلاب والموقع
الجغرافي والتضاريس الرائعه من جبالها
لوديانها لصحارها لبحيراتها وكذلك للدفئ
وحفاوه ابنائها كل ذلك يملئني دهشه وتعجبا
حتى في اقصى الظروف الاقتصاديه بالاضافه
الى طيف المهارات والحرفيه العجيب والطعام
والموسيقى والازياء كل ذلك رائع غير ان
السياسته هي التي تصيب كل ذلك بالخيبه
والفشل
ولا يسعني الا ان امل وادعو الله ان تجد
طريقا للتعافي من ازمتها الحاليه كما
اتمنى ان اجد في حياتي باكستان يفخر بها
ذو الاصول الباكستانيه من حول العالم وهذا
سؤال اطرحه دائما على الحكومه الباكستانيه
على اختلافها كلما زرت باكستان فاقول لهم
نحن لا تزال تربطنا علاقه بباكستان لان
امي وابي ينحذران من هناك ولكن هل لاولادي
تلك العلاقه نفسها والان وقد اصبحت جده
فهل سيكون لاحفادي اي رابط لباكستان واذا
فشلتك المحافظه على الصله واهتمام مثلها
هؤلاء كذلك فشل ذريه ان لم يكن هؤلاء
معنيون بزياره البلد والاستجمام هناك
والتعامل التجاريا معه فمعناه انكم حكمتم
على انفسكم بالموت لذا ابقى متفائله لانني
لا اجد بديلا عن ان اكون متفائله ولكنني
امل حقا ايتمكنوا من حل ازمتهم السياسيه
جدا بان
نساهم عبر المقابله في اطلاع جمهور عربي
واسع على هذه التجربه المهمه او
الاستثنائيه لشابه مسلمه بريطانيه سياسيه
حاضت كل هذه المعارك وكل هذه التجارب
وتولت مواقع قياديه رئاسه حزب المحافظين
الوزاره في كاول وزير مسلم في حكومه
بريطانيا عضويه مجلس الاوردات والنظام
الذي تقومين فيه الان ايضا في قضايا سواء
مجتمعك وقضايا المسلمين بشكل عام شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الفرصه
مشاهده الكرام شكرا لكم على طيب المتابعه
القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل مع
حلقه جديده ومقابله جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]